bonne journée soit rentré pour le dîner
salut
bonjour Catherine
et voilà vos filles Angela et Catherine
c'était il y a 7 heures et c'est la
dernière information qu'on est
Angela si vous entendez ce message on
vous
aime à la maison
vous l'avez retrouvé
des deux
là tu peux dire à ton père combien de
temps tu es parti quelques heures
peut-être
ma puce t'a disparu trois jours
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu as dit j'ai rien dit du
tout
pourtant je t'ai entendu parler
ça va
je sais pas où elles sont allés mais
elles ont rapporté quelque chose avec
elle le corps et le sang de Jésus-Christ
le Corps et le Sang le Corps et le Sang
Catherine le Corps et le Sang
le corps et le son le temps et le sang
Catherine
vous avez déjà vu une chose pareille
on connaît ça
[Applaudissements]
vous avez de l'expérience en matière de
possession
je crois que vous pouvez nous aider à
ramener la fille
l'exorcisme est un rituel chaque culture
chaque religion à sa propre méthode il
va falloir utiliser chacune d'elles
[Musique]
c'est déjà rencontré
qu'est-ce que tu as fait
le battement de son cœur il bat à
l'unisson
[Musique]